cuatro puntos en general el primero que
yo bailén dejó claro que no hay duda de
que la alianza transatlántica es muy
importante para él resaltó además la
importancia de volver a actuar de forma
conjunta con la otan dijo que un ataque
para uno es un ataque para todos y ahí
agradeció entonces el rol que jugó la
unión europea en la guerra contra el
terrorismo que han librado eeuu en el
medio oriente precisamente en esta
alianza transatlántica y la importancia
de la otan dijo que europa y eeuu
comparten los mismos valores sobre todo
el valor democrático y ahí viene el
segundo punto y es que dijo yo bailén
que la democracia está en un punto de
inflexión que está bajo asalto que hay
que prevalecer en el sistema democrático
que hay que renovar y fortalecer la
democracia y que salvar precisamente la
democracia es la meta crucial la meta
más importante que debe tener
europa y eeuu en ese sentido entonces
punto sería entonces como las amenazas a
esta democracia que plantean china rusia
irán y otros países sobre todo china y
rúsia mencionó yo vaivén como china ha
usado el sistema económico internacional
para su favor manipulando la moneda
manipulando el rol que juegan sus
empresas aprovechándose precisamente del
sistema económico internacional para
venta para ventaja de china y de beijing
y mencionó también a rusia dijo como
rusia alguna manera ha usado la
corrupción para atacar para hacer daño
al sistema de gobierno estadounidense y
mencionó también como pues rusia ha
aprovechado también todo este tema de su
inteligencia para hackear sus elecciones
recordemos que en el días anteriores se
había dicho que rusia se iba a ser
responsable de sus ataques de
cibernéticos a las elecciones
estadounidenses y pues un cuarto punto
para resaltar sería también el tema
climático y el tema
de la vacuna yo bailé dijo precisamente
como usted lo mencionaba que va a
aportar estos 4 mil millones de dólares
a la lucha para que los otros países los
países en vías de desarrollo también
tengan acceso a esta vacuna y mencionó
también que se trabajará con sus aliados
europeos para lograr eso para lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño vacunando no
solamente a los países desarrollados
sino a los países en vías de desarrollo
finalmente pues si se refirió a irán
como lo habíamos dicho y dijo que pues
está abierto a un diálogo con irán para
poder pues abordar el tema nuclear y que
trabajará para que los grupos
terroristas precisamente no accedan a
eso a las armas nucleares en él